Yeah so this is a really
interesting puzzle
because it turns out the puzzle itself
is wrong. So not only do you have to
solve the puzzle you have to figure out
what the puzzle really is.
It combines two of my interests: error
correction and sequences.
So I found this sequence on a website,
actually a Dutch website,
although that's irrelevant. It's a
sequence that came up as part of a quiz.
The quiz begins by asking you to
identify
various things, looks like
some kind of a thing-
(Brady: I know that word!
I know that word;
voorwerp,
that means object.
- Aha! The third page
has a number sequence
on it and they ask you
what's the number that goes where the
question mark is?
And the sequence goes 1,
2, 6, 21,
85, question mark, followed by 2586. Now
you stare at this
and you cannot figure it out; I didn't
see any pattern.
So at the end you can look up the answer
and the answer they give is 430.
(So you had to cheat to look up the
answer?)
- I cheated to look up the answer,
because I couldn't figure it out! And
since I am supposed to be an expert in
sequences I wanted to know,
what is the sequence that I couldn't
figure out? And once
I knew what they thought the answer was
I could figure it out.
And so what they did
had a mistake in it. How do you go from
6 to 21?
You add 1 and multiply by
3 and we get 21. So how do
you go from 2 to 6?
You add 1 and you multiply by 2;
add 1 you get 3 times 2 is 6.
How do you go from 1 to 2? You add
1 and multiply by 1;
1 plus 1 is 2 times 1 and you
get 2. Okay,
so so you stare at this and you say 'how
do you go from 21 to 85?'
Well if you add 1 and multiply by 4
you do not get 85, you get 88.
The person making up the test did it in
the wrong order.
They multiplied by 4, to get 84,
and they added 1 and they got 85.
How did they go from 85 to 430?
They added 1
to get 86 and multiplied by 5
and got 430.
- (So they started doing it)
(right again?)
- They started doing it right
again,
so that's the answer.
- (How long did it)
(take you to figure out what the mistake)
(they'd made was?)
Well the pattern- once you look at how
you might go -
this is something you always do when
you're looking at a sequence and there's
no obvious
mathematical rule - you say to yourself,
how can I go
from 2 to 6? How do I go from 6
to 21? You try to think of a way
to build it up and, well, there's a
this part is one of many possibilities
but it works and so, well, all right then
it became clear that there was a mistake.
[Preview] It's one of the
most basic things that
we can do. And even now,
even when we have digital images from
great big telescopes,
we still get a lot of information by
looking at them with our eye.